what's going on reject nation greg here
i was looking online and apparently
daniel rpk who is uh one of them
scoopers out there in terms of like
the scoopers in this little pop culture
zeitgeist i have found him to be one of
the most reliable
certain trailers or news that's going to
be reportedly coming out
i have found that he has been one of
like undoubtedly one of the most
consistent
uh out there and you guys might have
heard people talk about it before
already how the lizard is supposed to be
appearing
in spider-man no way home he recently
came out and was saying that he can 100
confirm that the lizard from amazing
spider-man 1 will continue to carry on
in the spider-man franchise with
spider-man
no way home is featured part of the
sinister six the lizard i think has had
such a weird
journey when it comes to the marvel
films
you know you had dylan baker in the
raimi films who it sounded like sam
raymond didn't even really care
like a lot of us were under the
impression that eventually he would
become kurt connors would become
the lizard but i don't think sam remy
actually had official plans to
do that or was really dead set or
committed to doing that and then he
comes into the amazing spider-man one a
lot of people were kind of let down by
it
and you know hearing this news it got me
excited i think the actor who plays and
if i'm going off memory here uh rhys
if fonz i believe is his name he might
be just saying it wrong
but i thought he did an alright job in
the film and
if you follow any of the behind the
scenes on the amazing spider-man 1
so many of his richly nuanced
scenes were just eliminated from the
movie
matter of fact uh one of the channels
that i adore
a channel called high top films who has
had his controversial takes
on the tom holland spider-man movies in
terms of video essays i don't agree with
him
on a lot of them however he's still my
favorite
video essay youtube channel i love
everything's gotta say
uh i always respect the way he
formulates his opinions he did a video
essay on the amazing spider-man one that
i watched like
a year ago or something like i don't
remember when but he he has a pretty
great breakdown of that movie and it
really did
shine even more of a light on man they
really cut down a lot of what would have
made a very powerful
compelling nuanced performance villain
in the amazing spider-man one part of me
is like oh you know that's
i'm excited that he gets to come back if
it is
rhysaphons being able to do the role i
imagine they're gonna give him a
different character design
from everything we've been hearing and
especially with the way how they are
changing the aesthetic of some of these
people like
you have jamie foxx who's undoubtedly
coming back as
elektra who's gonna have a different
design in this movie
there's like versions of this i feel
like the movie will make it more clear
if they are directly
from those franchises or not i imagine
they are
and i feel like with the lizard they'd
probably give them a redesign because
i'm hearing electro green goblin will
have a redesign
doc aqua look a little bit more
traditional to the rainy film for the
lizard some people didn't like design
either
that was like passable back then i feel
like they got to improve upon that and
i'm hoping
that they get to have the lizard carry
on in future spider-man movies or in the
sony spider-verse because the lizard is
like a fantastic
spider-man villain when it came to
growing up on the 90s animated
tv series that was one or like the
lizard
is constantly like a go-to image in my
brain i want to see them brought back
and
the thing though is if they are bringing
back like toby maguire andrew garfield
or any of these other villains some of
these villains already did such an
amazing job
and and like are the heroes have done
such an amazing job and there's some
villains that were here being brought
back who probably deserve a little bit
more justice
done for their characters as opposed to
getting the treatment that they got
in the standalone movies that already
happened i'm sure jamie foxx that was
part of why
maybe he was wants to come back is
because elektra was kind of clowned on
i think he would want a chance to show
that he can make this character really
cool
and i'm hoping that with the lizard
coming back considering that they
deleted
so many of his powerful scenes in the
movie thing that would have made the
movie better
his performance overall better if he
does come back i am hoping
that there's something in there that
will make it feel very rewarding and
cathartic
for that character to return to the
spider-man franchise especially if
you're plucking him out of the amazing
spider-man
one i just kind of had like a big stream
of consciousness thought process on this
that was flowing out of my brain when i
read the news that uh daniel rpk was
able to confirm this like i said i
really believed the guy just curious
what do you guys think does it excite
you at all that the lizard's coming back
is it something you don't even care
about what would you want
from this was there anything about the
redesign would you want rhysaphons i
don't know if i'm saying right would you
want him to come back to reprise the
role specifically leave your thoughts
down below
curious to hear what you got to say
still can't wait for that trailer though
man it's going to be a cool trailer
see you guys